parece que esto es buenos datos se
apoyan en el gran aumento de las
exportaciones que más factores explican
este crecimiento y ha sido una sorpresa
o ya se esperaban cifras como estas
Pues bueno Muchas gracias por tenerlo en
el programa yo esperaba 1.4 o sea salió
más fuerte de lo que yo esperaba es una
buena noticia y la composición del
crecimiento como dices tú quien tuvo
mucho que ver con exportaciones que
claramente es una buena noticia y menos
importaciones pero que es poco probable
eso sí Hay que decirlo y es importante
que la audiencia lo sepa es poco
probable que en el cuarto trimestre
volvamos a tener una un performance de
las exportaciones tan positivo Entonces
por ese lado yo creo que que no lo
volvemos a ver y creo que la parte que
no es tan buena es que sí se desaceleró
en una forma importante el consumo
aunque se desaceleró un poco menos de lo
que esperaba yo el consumo creció
1.4%, trimestre trimestre yo esperaba
uno por ciento anualizado Entonces es
una buena noticia que hubiese crecido un
poco más pero todo lo que toda la
evidencia que estamos viendo en este
momento en la economía es que muy
seguramente al final del año el cuarto
trimestre la el consumo de ser menos eso
Por ejemplo no lo aviso Amazon hoy
esperando que las ventas en la última
parte del año sean un poco menos fuertes
Comparado a lo que se esperaba apenas
unos meses porque porque pues hay más
inflación hay menos confianza
el el sector inmobiliario está
desacelerándose fuertemente en todas
todas esas cosas comienzan a incidir en
la expectativa de crecimiento Pues
precisamente de todo esto último que nos
Comenta quería preguntarle porque llegan
las elecciones de medio término y la
economía es uno de los puntos
principales por la preocupación para los
estadounidenses ha indicado usted como
bien ha dicho que ha crecido un 1,4 es
un 0,6% menos respecto al trimestre
anterior está venciendo el medio el
miedo de las familias a las cifras
reales o realmente la inflación y otros
factores son preocupantes para ellas
No yo pienso que a ver yo pienso que hay
el definitivamente la inflación afecta
Pues eso lo sentimos todas las personas
que vivimos en Estados Unidos y que la
el dinero alcanza para menos es bueno la
verdad esto esto Esto es cierto que es
un fenómeno mundial en todas partes está
pasando lo mismo Entonces eso afecta por
un lado también la caída de los precios
de las acciones como en Estados Unidos
casi todas las familias tienen algo que
ver con el con el Mercado o sea con el
dow Jones con el nasdaq etcétera porque
la gente tiene sus cuentas de retiro y
invertidas en estos activos entonces en
el subconsciente cuando caen los precios
de las acciones la gente tiende a
ponerse un poco más parca con su gasto
entonces por eso gasta menos y es
obviamente afecta Y por último es algo
que se ha estado es muy claro es que con
la con el mayor con el incremento tan
fuerte que se ha visto en las tasas de
interés Pues la verdad es que comprar
una casa para una familia por medio en
Estados Unidos hoy en día está muy
difícil porque se ha subido la cuota de
la una forma brutal más del doble
Entonces todo esto va a comenzar a
afectar y yo creo que es una de las
razones por las cuales es bien probable
el partido republicano gane las
elecciones en el congreso que recupere
la cámara y que recupere el senado
también si ya actualmente Qué está
haciendo el gobierno debayden para
mejorar la vida de las familias y en
caso de que el partido republicano
tuviera el poder de las cámaras usted
dice que es improbable pero en caso de
que llegara ese poder del partido
republicano que podría pasar con esas
leyes para las familias
Pues la verdad es que esto Esto es un
tema que le Hubiese pasado a cualquier
persona fuese presidente byden no
hubiese ganado trompo otra vez lo más
probable es que te tendríamos que vivir
este exceso de inflación porque lo que
sucedió entre 2020 y 2021 y 2022 es algo
que no tiene precedentes o sea realmente
nadie había cerrado nunca la economía
global nadie había impreso el 40% del
producto interno bruto en liquidez para
tratar de evitar el colapso completo de
la economía y pues todas estas políticas
que no sabíamos Cómo iban a funcionar
tienen efectos estos como si uno utiliza
una medicina experimental en un paciente
puede que el paciente se salve Pero va a
tener efectos efectos secundarios lo que
estamos viviendo hoy en día son efectos
secundario Entonces qué se puede hacer
al respecto la verdad dejar que pase el
tiempo y y darle espacio a la economía
para reacoplarse a las nuevas realidades
Entonces eso va a tomar tiempo